We all love a great story, so this lesson should be a fun one.
But I want you to remember that students need to see that story originates from
God himself. Again, this is another pointer to God showing students that God exists
because we have these things, because we have such a thing as story, because we can
tell great stories, and as people that reflect the image of God, we get that from
Him, and it's awesome. And your students hopefully will see that at the end of this
unit. And a fun way to do this is to find different stories, whether it be your own
story or maybe some of their stories or someone that you know.
It could be a book. It could be a movie.
But you want to find within those stories redemptive themes, themes of salvation,
those kinds of things. And you'd be surprised how many different stories are
actually based off of or have biblical themes buried within them.
So now you are officially halfway through the curriculum.
You've had some time to take inventory of where you are with your students, where
you are with your leaders and your small groups and the community and those types of
things. You've had a chance to step back and take a look at all that and see how the
year is going so far. Now it's time to evaluate.
Now this might not be something you're used to doing, but I highly encourage it.
I think it's really helpful in moving forward.
So we're going to call this your midterm.
So get ready because you have a quiz and a test coming up and you're going to
need... no I'm just kidding. I have two suggestions.
It's super simple. First thing is something that I've been doing for years with
students and I think is awesome, is have them do something.
Instead of just having them listen and maybe engage in discussion, might pick out
one, might pick out several, but have some students pick one of their favorite
lessons, a favorite topic of a part of a lesson, and either teach it back, lead a
discussion, do something with it that's fun.
It doesn't mean anything crazy or super complicated, but just to help
you and help your leaders get an idea of are your students digesting this and are
they able to communicate it back if they can accurately communicate something back
to you they've got it it's a simple easy way to determine whether or not they're
tracking with you you can ask them all day long and they might say yes but when they
try to say it they're all over the place and they don't get it but if they can sort
of teach it back and then we'll kind of compel other students and it changes things
up and it's kind of fun and something different and they can have some fun with it.
But this is a really good time to do that now that you are halfway through.
The second thing is take a look at where you struggled with, right?
So you don't wanna keep moving forward if for some reason you got stuck on something
else. So now might be a good time to think about, well, how do I unstick
myself from this particular topic if you have something that maybe just either you
weren't comfortable with, maybe they didn't get, at.
Maybe you want some reinforcements.
Maybe there were some additional questions that you just couldn't answer.
And maybe it's just a matter of you sitting down and doing some more research and
figuring it out. That'd be awesome.
Maybe it's an additional video you find someplace else, or maybe it's bringing in
the experts. Maybe it's bringing in somebody.
On our website at AwanaYM.org, we are going to have for you a list
of potential people that you can get a hold of.
Can't guarantee they're going to come, but you can get a hold of them to see if you
can schedule a time to bring in one of many apologetics experts to help
you or do a special event or do something to further the sticky point or
just further a discussion that was already started.
So great job getting this first half of the year completed.
I know these first few months probably have been difficult.
There's been some topics that you had to tackle that maybe you've been a little less
than comfortable with and some things that maybe have been challenging for you and
your students. But I know you guys have done a phenomenal job of getting the
information to the students and engaging with them at a high level and making this
stuff super relevant and stressing its importance as they continue their walk with
Christ. And if you're struggling anywhere and for any reason on anything, please
reach out to us. We are here to help you.
You can email us, you can hit us up on Twitter or Facebook.
We have a series of videos called In Two Minutes that we design specifically for
students and in the comments below those, we invite students to ask additional
questions and through those questions, we will continue to add additional videos and
answer additional questions. Again, we are here to help you.
Please reach out to us and we will help you in any way that we can.